okay good evening I Kris Naylor being
the acting returning officer at the
election for the Member of Parliament
for Dagenham and radom to hereby give
notice the number of votes recorded for
each candidate said election is as
follows
Denis original breeding Green Party
candidate five hundred and forty four
votes Jonathan Curtis Labour Party
twenty two thousand nine hundred and
fifty-eight Jonathan Harold fryer
Liberal Democrats 465 Peter James Harris
UK Independence Party 3246 Terrence
London Concordia 85 Julie Marcin the
Conservative Party candidate eighteen
thousand
a Leslie Williams sturdy of the British
National Party 239 votes number of
ballot papers were rejected as follows
once an official mark non-voting for
more than one candidate than the vote
was entitled to 22 being unmarked or
wholly void for uncertainty 51 the
overall turnout was 65 point zero two I
do hereby declare that Jonathan Curtis
is Juli elected as Member because and
looks woolly I sort of think returning
officer and thank all of the council
workers for the tireless work brother
David an excellent fantastic on the
Tampa Police so their work throughout
the campaign very difficult serve
themselves
I don't thank all the other candidates
it's a given the fact that a number to
say here only two years ago it's a big
lie put the band back together given
some results we might be back again
pretty soon I do want to say I think
it's been conducted in a very civil way
and then it's been you know enjoyed and
I just wanted to say a couple of points
firstly um this is the third election in
a row that I've been consistently told
that we're going to lose the election
only one we recommended that we want to
well I think and I think that is simply
down to an extraordinary group of people
who ran and executed a breed strategy
and then why organizers and activists in
the Dagenham and reigning position I'll
just sort of torment all my great
appreciation to you've been an absolute
joy to work with bison legal records
thank you very much and all sort of
things
I also offense we are friends of
Berkeley whether party you've been
fantastic and very
and reg'ment and the world continues and
back to work smart so thank you very
much evil in the dead people thank you